お前らこれが何回か分かるかと
そうこれはですねー
なんか最近実は者最近 twitter でハンバーガー1ない分プレゼント
キャンペーンって言う
マクドナルドの公式アカウントでそういうキャンペーンがあったあったんですけど
bar 年ん
日頃の行いませんか俺様がい記事内部当たっただけさ
あちょっと江別入れた次れたけど
こんな感じです本当にねちょっとを習う違っているだろう
本当に本当に担任は1年分回阿部なと思って口応募したらマジでたまたま当たった感じ
なんだよ
マクドナルドさん明日ツイッターで高貴なんですよおめでとうございますみたいな
マーサーが冗談かと思ったけどピカチっぽかったですね
に入っては
羨ましいなぁ
こわいなさんマジかよ
ハンバーガ一年分ってことだからマックカード36,500円部らしいです
[音楽]
もう
[拍手]
うん
すげー
どうも
こんなこんな大きいのっ
マクドナルドさ僕に私ちゃんやばいっすよあとそれをもうそれをこう狙って私だから
こう
あの人はハンバーガー100個買ったからなんかありがとうございます的な
まさか分わー
やべぇマッカーだよねえっていくえぐいえぐえぐ
このルールでキルレぐいとほんのああああ
古語あったないやえぐいだってこんなマックカード見たことないぜ
ああがえええええ
で思いさせて
[音楽]
んだねー
まあ冒険が今だけマックカードがあればね
することはただ一つというわけで次回のとかは班番外地年譜
食ってみたをすると思えば
しないです
さすがにしないですよ無理でしょだって100個の時
ハンガーが100くってもあんな感じだったから1年分くってみたともう絶対無理だす
やろうとも思わないし
ハンバーガー食ってみた人でかブッチャーし
別にいいかなと思ってさ今回は
こちらのマックカードプレゼントしますみなさんに
イェーイ位
[音楽]
まぁこれでいいと思います僕はいつも動画を見てくださっている皆さんのおかげで僕が
コスでおバカな動画も撮れて寿司
ひょっとしたら皆さんのおかげでまあカードが当たったかもしれないし
いろんなことを考えましたよ
ファミーに全部あげようかとか一人で知念分
ちまちま使おうかとかマジで市ね聞くってみたしようかとか色々考えたんですけどもう
君たちのおかげな動画を見てくださっている皆さんのおかげで僕が youtube
やっていけてるっていうこともあるんで
今回はちょっと本当に些細なお礼ですが本当にいつもありがとうございますっ有機物を
込めて
プレゼント客します
でも大体考えたんですよ後からしっかり聞いてくださいねもう
700個プレゼントです
そう今ここに365個分なって65飛べばもう自分のものにします
妻ないなオレ送りたいから受けて部分は俺のもんにしてねこれな300個分をみなさん
にプレゼントするんですけど
ハンバーガー100個が2名
ハンバーガ50校2名って感じでまあトータル300校ですね300校4名様に化け
させてプレゼントして
プレゼントしますまだまだまだだよこれからもうみんな当たるみんなどれ可能性がある
からちょっと待ってたなと応募資格なんですけどちょっとね1バーカーと思っている
こと
で2つ目がはじめ冊をこのチャンネルですねこのチャンネルと僕の
もういっこさん寝られるんですけど肇社長2っていう2つの youtube
チャンネルを登録していることです
この応募資格は別にそうする事でもないし全然誰でもできると思います
横暴方なんですけどこの動画を
動画にコメント一人生きてください1回だぞもう2階瞬間も俺はもうお前のことをやら
なきゃ
間に見るからね1人1回コメントしてください
でそのコメント内容はもう普通にくださいアーバーくださいみたいなコメント大
くださいそれ欲しいっていう意志が伝われば僕は
いいんでー
くださいとかよこせとかとりあえず補正になっていう意志が伝わればもうそれで
バッチリです当選者を選ぶ方法なんですけどまだ決めてないんですけどまぁコメント
どうこうよりランダムで選ばせて頂きます
4名の方ですねハンバーガ100後半バーが100校5050個で4名の方はランダム
で選ばせて頂きます
応募の締め切りが5月中5月31日土曜日まで5月30日土曜日の夜24時まで
この動画のコメント欄で待ってます
過ぎたら全部無効になります発表は録画中です
ちょっとまだ日まではっきり決めてないんですけど
チャンネル登録してたらその僕が動画だしたら通知がくるんで当然発表の動画夫婦す
可能性が少ないと思うので登録してたら大丈夫だと思いますってな感じです
僕はもう6500円分寺行ったら全部
じゃたれるんだよ
偶にはこういう使い方もいいんだと思います
誰もそうしてないでしょだって誰も損してないよね
ただでもらったし
やマクドナルさんには申し訳ないひょっとしたら1年分くってみたって嘘レンズをして
ほしかったから
この僕にくれたのかもしれないその人は誰も分からないただ一つ言えるのは僕はこの
カードを本当にたまたまゲットしたわけで僕の多大な感謝の気持ちで素敵と
4名にしか当たらないんで
みんなに食われないのは非常に残念なんですけどそういうわけにもいかないのでそこら
へんはご了承願います
というわけでみなさんぜひ
ハンバーガーシャックいたやつ動画にコメントしてください
まずてこと皆さんいつもありがとうに動画見てくれて
というわけだ
ハンバーガー尺欲しいやつコメント待ってるぜ
持っていたの
ん
[音楽]
んの